because i just love the human aspect of
stories and the
i guess you know almost human life is
more interesting
because weird [ __ ] happens that you
couldn't even predict yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think it's so interesting and
obviously like i also think the summing
salt is really similar to
uh frederick newton which is like mike
down the rabbit hole yeah down there
which is like literally like my favorite
channel on youtube i still haven't seen
his new one
no i haven't seen it i just think the
sheer amount of like dedication to the
story
and getting all the facts there is just
insane and like i think every time i get
drunk i watch that wings of redemption
that's the problem with that's the
problem with newton though is that like
every time he does upload a video
it's like a yay moment as well as an oh
[ __ ] moment because it's a yay moment
because he uploads like once everything
like this yeah
but it's an oh [ __ ] moment because it's
like okay what day in my calendar is
free
so watch this video you know there are
some content creators that you just
watch
immediately yeah and there's some
content creators where you make mental
note
you're like they have a low degree and
you're like okay i gotta find i gotta
find time like right opinion is the
exact same thing right
yeah every time he uploads it's like oh
it's another two hour video by right
opinion it's gonna be a banger but
man i'm not free for like three days i
have so much respect for my opinion
because normally like i
[ __ ] like i can't stand commentary
channels mostly yeah yeah because it's
it's it's just like the biggest
free-for-all it's like i don't know why
some people have like are so [ __ ]
loud and i don't know why some people
listen to
other people it's just and it's almost
always biased yeah it's so biased it's
always a [ __ ] mess
but dude if right opinion makes a like a
video about you i'm [ __ ] listening
i mean i was i was in one of his videos
yeah yeah exactly
yeah i was in one of his videos thanks
for that like if i get destroyed by
right opinion i'm like yeah
i did something wrong my bad my bad but
that's the thing right it's like when
when people were telling me that i was
in like a right opinion video yeah in my
head i was like yay and
[ __ ] at the same time it's like you got
a cameo
yeah i got a cameo but it's like is it
gonna be good is my career over oh my
god yeah luckily i was fine
because he has like such a good skill
and breaking down
the key components about what you know
someone's like personal mistakes
yeah and it just tells it how it is yeah
yeah yeah with without
without like he's he is obviously biased
but every time he is like
has any kind of bias in it he says it up
front
he in the end he lets the viewer make
their own opinion rather than telling
the viewer
how you know what opinion they should
have like he presents the facts
he presents his biases and then he
doesn't say hey you should [ __ ] hate
this person he just he just says
you make you know it's kind of like you
make your own opinion right now
yeah i mean i i obviously i watched the
[ __ ] four hour video in one go
because i was [ __ ] dying that day
no [ __ ]
it felt like it felt like it was just
repeating at times but that's because he
he does repeat his real life multiple
times
i think uh the only video that i was
kind of like male and i think he made a
video on like the animation community
and i remember feeling like all right
this is kind of like all right kind of
meh
is that the dan is a plan no no no that
one was good i like that it was like it
was talking about the animation
community and i think how
they all rely on each other for success
and it was kind of like warning that
they shouldn't but like
i really didn't feel like it was like i
was like okay cool i mean it doesn't
really say anything
yeah um but i mean overall yeah he's i
mean
just amazing at presenting an opinion
yeah also a frederick newsome by the way
is uh because he didn't explain what it
was he's like he does like documentary
on
anything basically a person or a yeah
it's so well done that it's just like oh
my god like yeah again
here's a video on wings of redemption
who i had no idea who that was but i
watched the full like two hour like 30
minute thing yeah
yeah yeah amazing it's so yeah it's it's
nuts how people can just
make a compelling narrative about
anything especially about something
where it's like i never knew about this
never cared about it but yeah
i guess now that i'm here i'm invested
yeah because i feel like i watch that
content not only
because it's uh because it's
entertaining but i also like as
as this is my job i can appreciate the
workshop
and like i appreciate because they they
also break down
as a youtuber like how the best way to
present yourself online is and how and
the mistakes of what not to do write
that
that's exactly that's exactly the point
right because they break it down in such
in in they break it down so well that
you can
like if this is your job and like social
media is your job then you can literally
take advice about what not to do and the
mistakes that other people have made
it's like a self-help guide it really is
all right don't do that no dude okay
okay wait before we move on
like okay here's the question for you
guys have you guys
ever like rehearsed a kind of like an
apology video
even though you've done nothing wrong
right come on you must have thought
about it
oh yeah in my head i've thought about it
but i just sat there from the mirror
being like
oh no no no no like like not actually
rehearsing my hair
you wake up every morning and i practice
the side before and it begins you know
this is a really hard video in your head
you've thought you've thought about it
before like
okay like there's a few ways to go about
it right there's the double down there's
the do nothing there's the apologize and
admit
wrongdoing and from what i've seen on
youtube it seems to be unfortunately
that people always want an apology but
people who apologize to mit wrong doing
normally get the [ __ ]
the worst yeah yeah i've noticed the
people who double down
normally get away with it yeah so yeah
youtubers double the [ __ ] down
every time because like i i you know i
don't i don't have anything in my past
that i expect i'm gonna need to make an
apology video but
nobody [ __ ] expects to need to make
an apology video right
so like as you see as a youtuber i see
this i see this trend happening you know
i see like cancer cold happening
and i'm just like but what if i did need
to make an apology
like vsauce music i don't need to
apologize but what if i did
do you watch any other like documentary
channels similar to that because i have
a few actually you know
on the note of youtube i think that uh
emperor lemon makes good ones about
youtube
i don't know if i i know his name i i've
probably seen a few of his stuff with it
i feel like his presenting style i don't
really gel with but i think the way that
he talks about youtube yeah i think is
really well done
yeah and and he's clearly someone who is
i guess i can see parallels between
me and the way that he talks about the
internet and the way that like i was
you know from like age 10 i was glued to
the internet yeah he talks about like
you know how you know realistically
let's say i think you made a video about
youtube likes
right so you know on paper if you see 90
percent
likes to dislike ratio any mathematician
would be like that's great that's great
nine to one but a youtuber sees that and
things oh [ __ ]
why isn't it 95 exactly exactly so he
basically like did a whole video
explaining how like
the actual youtube like ratio system is
like 99 percent is good
yeah the eight percent is you've
probably pissed off a little bit of your
audience yeah yeah
95 is you've probably said something a
little bit bad yeah and anything below
90 is like you [ __ ] up yeah yeah which
is true
it is definitely true and he made a
video as well uh that was really well
done
uh i don't give a [ __ ] about nascar he
did a bit of thing about nascar was
really good he also made a video about
uh hungrybox a smash player
oh yeah yeah yeah and that was a really
really good documentary i do like i do
like watching i'm not subscribed to any
of them but i do like watching like
uh smash compilations every now and then
i mean the the smash documentary that
came out years ago was amazing on
youtube
yeah that was the documentary that got
me smashing into
not just got me to smash but got me into
youtube documentaries yeah yeah as well
i don't know i don't know who made that
but it was like this
very famous four-hour smash documentary
that is like
way out of date now because it it
detailed like the very very start of the
game
human story yeah it is they built up the
characters of the story
yeah and it did it uh other channels if
you guys like uh
frederick newton i know you probably
don't know these channels there's
anxiety war i don't know if you've heard
of them
they're not exactly well sorry sorry
[ __ ] there's the uh i don't subscribe to
a lot of the documentary yeah like
because again they just take up so much
time not anxiety well sorry i talk about
him though later he's [ __ ] strange
who yeah
atrocity guide she does videos similar
to frederick newton i know that
her voice is so [ __ ] chilling and
creepy that even the ones that aren't
scary
feel scary yeah and it's like all right
what's going to happen
what's going to happen very good